bonjour et bienvenue à diagonale la
leçon en ce lundi 15 mai 2000 alors
aujourd'hui je suis tout seul pour
présenter cette émission mais ce n'est
pas grave puisque l'émission sera de
bonne qualité quand même la dernière
fois donc lundi la lundi 17 17 avril oui
puisqu'il 3 lundi férié depuis nous
avons vu comment gagner la positio enfin
les finales élémentaire roi plus d'âme
contre le roi au roi plus tour contre
roy et ainsi de suite
alors une fois que vous savez gagner
avec avec ça c'est à dire avec juste une
pièce qui suffit une pièce lourde
une dame dont on peut revenir plus plus
plus en avant et gagner avec simplement
un pion puisqu'il suffira d'hommes
déception adam est ainsi donc vous aurez
roi et dames contre roy est la partie la
gagne est donc en fait aux échecs pour
gagner une partie il suffit d'un pion
avantages que vous pouvez acquérir dans
le milieu de jeu dans l'ouverture
en tout cas c'est quelque chose qu'on
fait fructifier et on arrive en finale
la fameuse finale roi epyon contre roye
donc cette finale
bien entendu est complexe il ya beaucoup
beaucoup de cas est étudié beaucoup
beaucoup de cas où est tout à fait et
notamment le cas le plus simple c'est
quand le pion avance tout seul et que le
roi adverse ne peut pas l'arrêter alors
on va tout de suite passé sur le sur
l'écran avec un premier exemple premier
exemple très simple vous voyez que les
blancs ont un roi en a deux les noirs
ont le roi henri iv et les blancs ont
juste cette petite différence ce sera le
thème de l'émission d'aujourd'hui un
pion de plus ce qui est tout seul sur
cette case f4 alors qu'est-ce que ça
qu'est-ce que ça entraîne et bien le
pion aux libres d'avancé et d'ailleurs
le roi noir a l'air assez loin c'est le
premier cas qu'on va étudier le roi noir
est trop loin et il suffit donc aux
blancs d'avancé le pion en jouant f5 les
noirs reviennent sur le pion avec roy b5
on continue à avancer en juin m6 roi ses
six f-16 et là on s'aperçoit que le roi
ne peut pas arriver pour arrêter le
tueur il peut jouer roi 17 mai les
blancs c'est pas grave il continue il
jouait fuite promotion dame est là après
reportez-vous à l'émission du 17 avril
pour savoir exactement comment gagner
cette partie
donc ça c'est le premier exemple tout
l'enjeu de la position est de savoir si
le pion va arriver à dame ou non alors
on va revenir au début et donc c'est un
cas où l'option blanc et éloignées on
est bien d'accord
le pion blanc est éloigné de l'action il
est sur la colonne f alors que les deux
rois sont complètement à gauche de
l'échiquier
alors comment savoir immédiatement si
cette position est gagnante ou nuls
c'est à dire qu en fait l'enjeu
maîtresse un pied droit noir avait un
temps date de plus c'est dire que si les
blancs joué par exemple 3 b2 qui perd un
temps dans cette position baignoire jour
et roye b 4 et cette fois ci n'aurait
plus qu'à aller manger le pion puisque
après f5 leroy revient ainsi de suite on
continue
sauf que là puisque les bleus ont perdu
un temps au début de variantes le roi
noir arrive juste à temps pour manger ce
pion là plus rien à faire on ne peut
plus le défendre et si on lave ans pour
faire promotion dame
pareil pour apprendre donc ici la partie
évidemment déclarés nuls donc reprenons
au début vous voyez cette position là
qu'est ce qui va vous faire dire si la
partie est gagnante nul et bien c'est
très simple c'est ce qu'on appelle le
carré du pion alors on va former avec
ses pions on va l'amener sur la
diagonale en diagonale on la mène jusqu
ici et là en forment un carré entre la
case diagonale et à castillon donc à
vous voyez toutes les classes vertes
cette délimite les cases ou si le roi
noir était dedans il pourrait stopper le
pion donc si c'est au noir de jouer bien
entendu le roi noir entrent dans le
carré du pion entre sur une des cases
verte et là va arrêter le pion comme
malheureusement ou heureusement pour les
blancs c'est à vous de jouer
il avance le pion un temps en avance
maintenant on peut voir le nouveau cas
réduction donc on reforme en corse est
ce petit schéma avec un carré comme ça
et là on voit bien que les noirs ne
peuvent pas rentrer dans ce quart est
donc tout simplement la position de la
position de départ ici après un f5 c'est
le cas numéro un ce cas là est gagnant 6
et auckland les nuls 6 et au noir de
jouer donc ça c'est un premier exemple
donc on va tout de suite en voir un
deuxième sur ce cas réduction là
effectivement on va former le carré et
on va s'apercevoir très très vite
donc là que je ne vous fait plus les
cases annexes que le roi noir est dedans
donc là c'est aux blancs de jouer il
avance laurent noir revient et attrapes
évidemment le pion évidemment puisque de
le carré étant de plus en plus petits
mais le roi noir est toujours dedans
donc la réflexion donc ça c'est le
premier premier exemple les premières
positions ou simplement le roi blanc et
or de l'action hors de l'action
puisqu'il ne peut pas venir y participer
le pion blanc est tout seul dans un coin
éloigné de l'échiquier et le roi noir va
essayé de l'attrapper donc la très
simple de toute façon les couples de
même il n'y a pas de choix pour les deux
camps simplement évidemment si on
calcule cette histoire de quart et on
voit tout de suite si l'option est
rattrapé ou pas
l'autre méthode est temps de calculer
brut c'est à dire voilà le pion avance
le roi bien là le pion avance le roi
bien là ce qui est plus long et moins
intuitif voilà donc deux exemples dans
le premier exemple le roi noir n'arrête
pas le pion dans le deuxième il arrive
juste au bon moment
ça fait deux possibilités donc voilà on
a vu ce premier cas où le roi plan
n'intervient pas maintenant on va voir
quand même que ça marche beaucoup mieux
quand on a froid et pion contre roy
c'est à dire que le roi blanc est aussi
dans l'action c'est notre prochain
exemple ici alors ça c'est plus
compliqué vous voyez les deux les droits
sont au centre et avant de commencer à
étudier cette finale je vais vous
présenter le principe de l'opposition
principe très très connue c'est les deux
rois sont en opposition
donc ils sont comme ça l'un en face de
l'autre
et quant à roy se déplace d'une case sur
la droite par exemple l'autre roi va
garder l'opposition en se déplaçant
également sur la droite devant lui ce
qui donne sur l'échiquier ici par
exemple le premier coup donc c'est au
blanc jouer c'est une tentative aura c4
hélas non voilà les noirs peuvent garder
l'opposition en jouant 3 et 6 donc ça
c'est une juste une idée d'opposition si
les blancs venaient en b3 il y aurait
trois baies 5
donc là c'est un exemple en faisant
complètement abstraction du pions blancs
et on voit que ça ça en finlande ayant
une voix on voit juste on voit pas grand
chose pour l'instant puisque on voit
simplement que les droits sont l'un en
face de l'autre
et qu'est ce que ça fait ça fait trois
cases contrôlé par les deux rois 3 càs
de vis-à-vis est en fait le principe de
l'opposition c'est que si un roi c'est
d'une de ces cases l'autre roi
immédiatement y aller donc dans quand
les droits sont en vis-à-vis le roi qui
va jouer va forcément céder des cars à
l'autre roi ça c'est un principe très
très important c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'opposition prendre l'opposition c'est
se mettre en face de l'autre roi
le forcer à nous concéder des cases donc
revenons sur la position de départ ici
les droits sont en opposition comme
c'est au plan de jouer on peut dire que
le dernier coup des noirs a été de
mettre leurs rouen des six est de
justement prendre cette fameuse
opposition ici tentatives pour gagner
rossé 4 donc très vite contré par les
noirs qui joue le roi en a eu cinq
attaques l'option forçant donc
complètement la défense des blancs roi
des 3 et maintenant les noirs repartent
derrière le pied enfin toujours devant
lyon le principe de défense quand vous
avez cette finale roy action contre roy
c'est à dire que le roi noir et devant
le pion blanc et le roi blanc et à côté
du cube blanc il faut toujours rester
devant évidemment si le roi par par
derrière s'ils s'aventurent plus loin
qu'il ne peut dans la position le pion
n'aura plus qu'avant c'est donc le roi
noir de rester dans le pion les blanches
au roi des 4 et la très important les
noirs prennent l'opposition avec trois
des six ici il n'ya pas d'autre choix
pour les blancs que d'avancer les pions
c'est à dire que si on commence à jouer
de travers c'est à dire roi c'est 4 3 3
c'est à partir sur les cases annexes qui
sont ici on perdra immédiatement le
contrôle de la case au 5 et le roi ne
s'aventurera dessus et obtiendra un
poste là intéressant donc on avance
nation aux 5 laurent noir restant de 6,3
blanc veut 4 hélas ici un très bon coup
joué par les noirs c'est le bon réflexe
dans cette position il faut aller sur la
case e set
il faut venir sur cette case là alors je
veux faire un petit retour en arrière
dans cette position il est très
important de venir sur la case ici qui
est en fait devant le pion toujours
parce que si on vient sur une autre case
ses terres si par exemple revenez sur la
case 17
ce ne serait pas précis parce que ça
permettrait aux blancs de prendre ce
qu'on appelle cette fameuse opposition
donc il faut éviter en finale de royan
contre roye de donner à son adversaire
la chance de mettre son roi en face du
vôtre c'est exactement ce que font les
noirs dans cette position là puisqu'ils
viennent sur la case hausse est hélas
les blancs ne peuvent pas prendre
l'opposition puisque ils ont l'option
blanc leurs propres pions qui les bloque
qui les empêche d'y aller donc toujours
le bon réflexe quand votre adversaire
est en train d'avancer on ne peut pas
l'empêcher d'avancer avec trois pions il
faut se décaler il faut reculer
face aux pions c'est le meilleur moyen
de défendre
trois des cinq donc la très très facile
on a plusieurs cartes on a le choix
entre six cases 5 4 seulement
mais évidemment avec l'habitude y en a
plus qu'une seule qui nous intéresse
c'est la case qui se met en face de
l'autre roi des rois 17e six échecs 3e
set
donc là on se met toujours devant le
pion c'est la règle de base les blancs
n'ont pas le choix ils doivent le rôle 5
est ici de la défense précise évidemment
même l'unique défense maintenant dans
cette position c'est de jouer roi en 1 8
donc même thème qu'avant les blancs
juste avancé d'une case et maintenant le
roi va 2e set en 1/8 et ici la seule
tentative des blancs il y en a deux en
fait ces rois des 6 euros à 6 donc
regardons d'abord leroy qui vient sur le
côté droit
les noir reprennent l'opposition qui ont
poussé cheikh roi en 8es ici les blancs
sont devant un curieux problème c'est à
dire que s'ils s'en vont n'importe où
ils vont perdre le pion donc il n'y a
qu'une seule case qui leur permet de
garder la défense de sion c'est la case
aux 6es là qu'est ce qui se passe c'est
tout simplement pâte pattes parce que le
roi est l'option blanc contrôler toutes
les cases c'est le pion contrôler les
deux cases rouges
ici en effet fuite et des 8 es le roi
contrôle les trois cases qui sont face à
l'autre euros donc ici c'est la position
de pâte qui est l'unique ressource
défensive des noirs dans cette finale
depuis le début donc reprenons quand
même depuis le début cette finale on
voit cette position là le roi noir lui
un cheminement extrêmement simple c'est
à dire que pour se défendre dans cette
position qui est nul il faut rester
toujours devant le pion et quand le roi
blanc vient à côté du pion se mettre
face à lui ce qui donne là vous allez
voir c'est très très logique roi des
trois là on reste devant lyon
les blancs tentent de progresser
évidemment les blocs on se met face à
eux le kg on avance on reste toujours
devant le pion c'est très simple roy 4
maintenant il faut une fois de plus
partir sur la case donc rester dans cet
axe l'acce du pion c'est capital dans
cette finale trois des cinq très facile
maintenant on se met en face du roi aux
six échecs
donc là il ya toute une mécanique qui
est qui est très très simple en fait qui
est toujours la même un étage plus haut
rome 5 3 8
roy donc là on l'autre possibilité
aurait t rois des 620 bureaux à 6 la
dernière fois et là on ne va pas en
reste huit évidemment puisqu'elle ça
permettrait à l'autre de faire dames en
virant des huit recettes 3,8 et
maintenant comme il ya plus de on ne
peut plus avancer on ne peut plus
reculer
c'est tout simplement date est donc nul
donc voilà un premier exemple de cette
finale roi lion contre roi le roi blanc
à côté de son propre pions et là le roi
noir doit rester toujours dans laxe ou
alors se mettre face au roi blanc quand
celui ci vient à côté de son pion
maintenant un autre exemple nouvel
exemple de cette même finale qui cette
fois ci n'est plus la même chose
alors pourquoi ce n'est plus pareil
puisque ça ressemble vraiment beaucoup
et bien la différence extrême c'est que
le roi blanc peut passer devant son
propre pions et c'est ça le moyen de
gagner dans cette finale donc c'est ce
qu'on va voir tout de suite le bon coup
dans cette position ces 3 e 4 alors
qu'est ce qui se passe ici c'est les
blancs qui prennent l'opposition cette
fois ci ils ont leurs pions derrière
leurs pions qui est en retrait et ça
c'est très important alors maintenant
vous voyez
sauf que ce que je disais au départ
c'est qu'on prend le contrôle de ces
trois cases la d34 verte
c'est au noir de jouer et quelles que
soient leurs coûts ils vont être obligés
de concéder une de ces cases et ça c'est
un gros problème pour les noirs c'est un
très gros problème dans cette position
puisque après 3 des 6 le roi blanc
évidemment profite de cette de cette
concession
et donc il bondit sur la case f5 le roi
noir donc doit reculer pour justement
rester devant lyon puisque s'il s'en
aller il y aurait plus aucun
il n'y aura plus aucune idée défensive
l'idée défensive et quand même
d'empêcher le pion d'aller à dame c'est
tout l'enjeu des finales euro action
contre roy sait si l'option arrive adams
et gagner donc ici recettes on reste
devant le pion et là vous voyez qu'on ne
va pas avancer notions tout de suite
puisque ça serait une faute grave
je veux 4 dans cette position après roy
f7 les noirs récupère l'opposition est
ici il n'ya plus moyen d'avancer re5
croisette
c'est ce qu'on a vu la dernière fois on
va montrer très très vite cette variante
puisque maintenant voûte et déjà être
habitué trois des cinq rois 17 pas moyen
de s'en détacher e5 là on reste devant
le pion aux 6 on reste devant le pion
roi des six wade 8 avec le fameux pacte
qui arrivent eux sept rois à 8,06 donc
variant du rapidement puisque c'est
exactement la même que la dernière fois
sur wyeth il ne faut pas avancer les
pions sinon ça serait tout simplement
partie nulle on joue au roi a eu 5 on
recommence on recommence exactement la
même chose sauf que là on a gagné une
case on est un cran au dessus et nos
pions est toujours derrière et ça s'est
très très bien il faut toujours avoir le
roi devant le pion on le rappellera
jamais assez en finale devant watts est
donc là le roi noir est parti à droite
donc on en profite évidemment pour
passer sur la gauche trois des six roi 8
3 6 on continue on reprend encore
l'opposition une dernière fois
roy d'éviter maintenant c'est l'heure
d'avancer le pion aux 4 laura noir doit
rester en face à eux cinq là on arrive
donc la photo sur cette position
c'est vraiment une position de base une
position élémentaire quel que soit le
trait la position est gagnante
il se trouve que ces trous noirs roi et
fuite 3,17 très très logique c'est un
coût qui ne se commente même plus tout
simplement ici à l'opposition laurent
noir de schiste doit choisir son côté
doit choisir son camp et de toute façon
le roi blanc ira dans l'espace créé de
l'autre côté droit il fuit 3,17
c'est un exemple très simple wife set et
alors maintenant là on arrive dans une
position typiques leroy contrôle les
trois cases du les trois pièces du pion
les trois cas ce que le pion doit
franchir pour arriver
il suffit donc de l'avancé sans se
soucier des coûts noir de six wife 6e 7
bref c'est de toute façon il n'y a plus
de défenses de huit dames et maintenant
c'est très simplement gagne en se
référant simplement dans les différer de
diagonale la leçon à l'édition du 12
avril vous saurez tout de suite comment
gagner roy et dames contre roy donc
c'était un nouvel exemple de cas de cas
avec trois options contre le roi donc
pour résumer tout ça
si le pion blanc le pion avance devant
le roi et que le roi noir est en face de
ce pion la position et deux nuls pour
défendre c'est très simple il suffit de
rester avec son roi devant le pion et de
prendre l'opposition quand c'est
possible
maintenant le moyen de gagner la finale
roi et pion contre le roi c'est de
passer le roi devant le pion de prendre
l'opposition de gagner du terrain c'est
à dire d'avancé avec le roi d'abord roy
rencontrera en avance et ensuite pour
finir amené le pion vers la vers la case
de promotion vers l'amitié manger voilà
donc on va passer à un nouveau cas le
pion h
le fameux pions h ce pion est très
spécial très particulier puisqu'il est
donc sur le sur la bande 2,6 ghz alors
ici position de départ extrêmement
simple les deux rois sont en opposition
ce qui veut dire en fait quand on voit
cette position que le roi blanc qui
étant un ne participera
vraisemblablement pas trop à la partie
puisqu'il bloqué par son homologue noir
qui étend à 3 donc le roi blanc ne
jouera pas un rôle déterminant ici
l'enjeu de cette position s'est une fois
de plus cela vous voyez tout de suite
qu'on est dans le premier cas qu'on a vu
c'est l'option est éloigné et le roi est
très loin aussi
donc là simplement c'est très simple ce
qui se passe dans cette position est ce
que le pion va à dame ou non donc comme
c'est aux blancs de jouer il joue h 2 h
4 et là on va refaire un p'tit quinquin
réduction juste pour vous rappeler
comment ça marche
le cas réduction ici
voilà et le roi noir
donc on voit très bien qu'il est très
très loin d'entrer dans le carré on va
quand même montrer ce qui se passe si se
dépêchent de revenir vers le pion il va
évidemment arrivé trop tard puisque
chaque camp ne joue qu'une fois par coup
et là tout simplement
les blancs jouent h 7 h 8 dames et ces
gagnants toujours cette fameuse émission
du 17 avril qui est très très importante
decideo donc ce premier cas de pions h
on voit que quand les rois sont éloignés
c'est à dire c'est là c'est simplement
la règle du carré la première est qu'on
a vu aujourd'hui maintenant nouveaux cas
avec le pion âge qui est cette fois ci
plus compliqué le roi noir étant
hashemite c'est à dire que le roi noir
est vraiment très très loin il est sur
la case de promotion prévue du pion
leroy plan étant le 4 et le pion blanc
est en hd
donc si ce n'avait si donc si ce pion h
avait justement été sur une autre
colonne sortait gagnant de façon très
très simple il aurait suffit d'amener le
roi de prendre l'opposition
ensuite une fois qu'on contrôle
pratiquement la casse de promotion de
pousser pions et c'était gagnant ici
avec le pion h il ya des gros problèmes
c'est à dire que tout simplement cette
position est nul
alors c'est ce qu'on va voir 3 et 5 ont
fait exactement la méthode qu'on a
mentionné précédemment
on amène le roi d'abord rage cette
rangée 5 et les noirs pour la défense
est extrêmement simple il suffit qu'ils
restent sur les 15 h 8 et g 8 et on ne
peut pas les en déloger
alors voyons ce qui se passe donc on
continue selon la fameuse méthode
d'abord le roi ensuite le pion roger
vite et maintenant on avance le pion h4
rouach 8 h 5
tout semble se passer comme dans le plan
aura j'évite est ici voilà c'est là
qu'on s'aperçoit du problème c'est quand
les noirs jour j'ai vite on ne peut pas
passer de l'autre côté on ne peut pas
passer à droite pour une raison très
simple c'est qu'il n'y a pas de case
l'échiquier d'en couper l'échiquier
faisant 8 sur 8 c'est indiscutable on ne
peut pas aller sur la case donc qui
serait ici i7 puisqu'elle n'existe pas
donc on est obligé de rester face au roi
les noirs jouera schmitt et on n'a pas
de plan pour progresser dans cette
position tout simplement
donc on joue à six mois j'ai vite
h7 rouach 8 et l'a donc une fois de plus
le même dilemme que précédemment soit le
roy quitte la défense du pion et après
trois professions c'est nul soit les
planches pour voir si c'est cette fois
ci ses pattes une nouvelle fois
obligatoire le roi contrôlons les cases
g7 et h7 est l'option contrôlant la case
à chocs 8e j'évite donc ici tout
simplement un pat cela c'est de toute
évidence la position n'est pas gagnante
cette position n'a pas gagné donc ça
c'est l'option h quand le roi noir et
c'est une règle avec le pion à quand le
roi noir et devant le pion il est sur la
casa suite c'est toujours nul et c'est
la même chose évidemment pour le pion à
qui est en fait linverse simplement le
côté gauche au lieu du côté droit donc
très simple
les conclusions de cette finale quand le
roi adverse le roi noir se trouve face
aux pions se trouve devant lyon sur la
classe de promotion quand ils contrôlent
la case à chocs huit g8 ou f8 votre pion
h ne gagnera pas donc sachez le en
finale le pion quand le pion et sur la
bande il est sur le côté de l'échiquier
c'est beaucoup plus dur de gagner avec
alors qu'un pion central ou un pion même
qui est donc sur les cases des fous des
cavaliers va gagner beaucoup plus
souvent dans beaucoup plus de cas de
figure sagan ira maintenant
nouvel exemple avec le pion h et dernier
exemple donc on va passer y passer tout
de suite ici
les noirs viennent de jouer roy en fuite
donc on voit que les blancs sont bien
avancés dans cette position ils ont déjà
le pion qu'il a donc l'idée est bien sûr
d'empêcher le roi noir d'atteindre ces
fameuses cases qu'on a cité avant les
casses j'évite th 8
parce qu'une fois qu'il est dessus sa
défense est très simple il n'y a plus
qu'à rester dessus et on ne peut plus
avancer à cause du pat donc l'idée
blanche et dire je vais jouer maintenant
rouages fait donc là à priori
j'empêche le roi noir devenir sur ces
cases là je contrôle la case de
promotion de mon pions donc on ne voit
pas ce qui va empêcher les banques
gagner dans cette finale apparemment ça
ressemble un gain élémentaire et
pourtant non puisque après roy f7 trois
fuites
c'est un exemple
le roi noir cette fois ci yves a utilisé
un stratagème défensive très très
intéressant il va jouer roi et fuite
il va en fait coller le roi blanc dans
ce coin de l'échiquier dans ce coin du
ring et le roi pour ne peut plus
maintenant se dégager pour laisser
passer son pion c'est ce qu'on va voir
donc on recommence rush cet or f7 est
par exemple on essaye d'avancer le pion
puisque là il n'y a plus moyen de sortir
de la boîte h6 là les noirs revient dans
et fuite c'est la casse clé la casa
fuite dans les finales avec pion à une
fois que vous l'avez atteindre vous
disposez des deux méthodes
la première est celle qu'on élit menacé
d'aller manger vite pour faire nul et la
deuxième est celle qu'on voit en ce
moment même c'est à dire le roi en effet
cette ici donc après roanne fuite trois
sets
on empêche le roi blanc de sortir de sa
boîte est suracheté à ton jeu roi et
fuite
et cette fois ci ce ne sont plus les
blancs qui provoque la pâte mais les
noirs puisque les blancs n'ont plus de
coups ils se sont fait complètement
enfermé le pion ne peut plus avancer et
le roi ne peut plus sortir puisque les
cases sont contrôlés donc ici tout
simplement on a vu les deux stratagème
défensif on en a on va revenir encore
une fois à cette position là après roy
et suite ici
deux choix pour les blancs de choix dans
cette position soit allé sur la casa
schmidt qui est en haut soit les sur la
case justice qui est à gauche et dans
les deux cas de figure les blancs
n'arriveront pas à passer donc on
recommence sur roy g6 ici la défense
c'est les noirs maintenant qu'ils vont
prendre la position devant le pion qui
vont jouer roi j'évite les blancs n'ont
plus d'autre choix que de jouer à cet
échec
ou sinon de toute façon ça ne servira à
rien ça ne progressera plus 3h vite et
maintenant rage 6 avec le fameux pattes
premier exemple donc si si dans cette
position après roy et fuite
les blancs décide de venir sur la casse
g6 là à ce moment là on voit bien que
c'est des noirs qui prennent possession
des casses de promotion du pion et c'est
fini maintenant deuxième cas les blancs
disent je vais moi-même allé en
hashemite là les noirs ne doivent pas
partir ne doivent pas se laisser
distraire
ils doivent en faire mais le roi blanc
sur cette case simplement jean roy et 7h
cet héroïque 8 créant le réseau de pâtes
donc alors maintenant pour conclure
cette finale c'est finale avec le pion h
il faut impérativement pour gagner avec
un pion h m notre roi sur la case g7
c'est à dire empêcher le roi noir de
revenir sur la case f8 cette case f8
c'est la case clé une fois qu'il y ait
ça lui donne les deux possibilités
défensives qui est soit d'aller
directement devant le pion soit d'en
fermer notre roi dans la boîte et avec
ces deux possibilités là une fois qu'il
est en fuite
il n'y a plus moyen de gagner donc pour
cela pour éviter ça il faut mettre leur
ou angers 7 ou autre possibilité
envoyez le pion avant que le roi adverse
ne puisse arriver dans le carré et ça
c'est le gain le plus élémentaire
donc en général des finales avec yoann
sont nulles et en général les finales
avec pion central sont gagnantes et on
va conclure là dessus avec une dernière
position qui est une étude de monsieur
trotsky donc un des plus grands un des
plus grands compositeurs d'études de
tous les temps qui a fait des très
belles études et qui s'est notamment
intéressé à la finale deux cavaliers
contre pions alors mon petite parenthèse
qui va être très très courte avec roy et
deux cavaliers on ne peut pas mater un
roi tout seul par contre les croates
deux cavaliers quand notre adversaire à
roye plus pions on peut gagner donc
c'est un peu paradoxal puisque on
rajoute du matériel à notre adversaire
et c'est ce qui permet de gagner
donc monsieur trotsky c'est très très
intéressé à cette position royer de
calais contre roy et pions il a
découvert dans certains cas que c'était
gagnant mais il a surtout composée des
merveilleuses études et notamment celle
ci donc là on est à la fin d'une étude
évidemment ça a commencé il ya quelques
coups déjà ça va nous permettre de
revenir sur un des thèmes qu'on a déjà
vu dans diagonale la leçon premier coup
dans cette position donc on voit qui est
un cavalier un roi une dame un roi un
pion donc pour l'instant on sort du
cadre de roy étions contre roanne mais
ça va nous permettre de rappeler un des
principes qu'on a déjà vu dans le sens
qui est le principe de la fourchette la
fourchette ou l'attaquent double inde et
plus généralement la tacc double ici au
premier coup on joue cavalier c6 le
cavadee vient ici attaque le roi et la
dame
donc il fait échec au roi et en même
temps attaque la dame le roi vient sur
la case des 5 par exemple
maintenant le cavalier prend la dame
tout simplement qu'elle les prend dame
au roi prend dame alors après c'est donc
ces deux coups d'introduction on arrive
dans la finale roi et pions
contre le roi est ici alors là donc je
vais vous laisser réfléchir quelques
secondes dans cette position quel est le
bon coup est-ce qu'il faut avancer les
pions ou m leroy devant le pion alors
effectivement en régie on dit qu'il faut
avancer le pion ce qui est évidemment la
faute puisque ici il faut jouer d'abord
le roi et ensuite le pion donc c'est ce
qu'on avait vu en début d'émission
il fallait jouer roi f3 c'est un
principe que philidor a mentionné depuis
le xviiie siècle
sauf erreur de ma part roy f3 toujours
le roi avant le pion maintenant wall5 et
là on est dans le plan le plan gagnant
on n'a plus qu'à tracer c'est
l'autoroute
vous connaissez déjà cette position
roger iv le roi noir revient à m6 ici on
prend l'opposition c'est très simple
grossiste donc si ça veut dire qu'on a
pris l'opposition il a été obligé de se
décaler on passe de l'autre côté rocher
rolf sept rois f5 on continue on revient
dans cette opposition toujours roi g7
roi aussi son continue on continue
d'abord le roi est ensuite l'option donc
là c'est vraiment c'est vraiment bien et
bien et bien montrer puisque une fois
qu'on a repoussés le roi noir jusqu'aux
limites de son camp c'est à dire ce
jusqu'à la huitième rang j'ai là c'est
l'heure maintenant on y va on avance le
pion f4 wife 8ème 5 laurent noir doit
choisir son côté il vengé witte roos est
hélas c'est très simple on contrôle les
trois cases donc quelles que soient les
couloirs vous allez avancer votre pion
c'est très simple donc ici revenons
juste sur la position de départ de cette
étude
après donc dans cette position-là
position normalement perdante pour les
blancs puisque les noirs ont une dame de
plus tout simplement on joue qu'avec ses
six échecs fourchette
ensuite on ramasse la dame c'est à dire
qu'on a simplifié la position dans une
finale royale contre roy est ici très
très simplement le bon réflexe ce n'est
pas d'avancer un pion puisque ça serait
nul immédiatement c'est de passer droit
avant le pion et c'est ce qui va vous
permettre de gagner cette position donc
petit récapitulatif général pour
conclure ces finales roi lion contre
roye première possible
et le pion cours adam et le roi ne
l'arrêtent pas c'est ce qu'on appelle le
cas réduction vous prenez votre pion
vous faites un carré avec la diagonale
tout simplement vous remarquez si le roi
et demi est dedans on n'est pas dedans
s'il y est et bien tant pis vous allez
perdre votre pion
s'il n'est pas dedans vous n'avez plus
qu'à l'avancé à les faire damer gagner
c'est très simple donc ça c'est le cas
où les rois sont éloignés de l'action
deuxième cas le roi est à côté du pion
sur les quatre centrales c'est à dire
sur les colonnes b c d e f ou g
c'est-à-dire toutes les colonnes sauf
les colonne latérale cas général le roi
est à côté du pion si le roi adverse et
devant c'est nul très simplement en
gardant le roi devant reculant comme ça
reculant toujours face aux pions et
prenons l'opposition c'est à dire se
mettre en face au roi a admis des qui
tente une attaque latéral donc la
défense nul sauf si les blancs arrive à
mettre le roi devant le pion à prendre
eux-mêmes l'opposition là il vous
forcera à partir d'un côté ou de l'autre
il va gagner de l'espace il va gagner du
terrain toujours en progressant avec
simplement son roi contre le vôtre et
ensuite il aura plus qu'à avancer ses
pions pour finir en arrivant adam
troisième cas le cas du pion h
donc la très très simple une fois de
plus le phénomène du car et c'est à dire
est ce que le roi et demi peut réussir à
attraper votre pion si oui tant pis
c'est nul vous allez perdre pions sinon
vous allez adam et vous gagnez autre
possibilité quand les deux rois sont
proches de l'action soit il arrive sur
la case f8 la fameuse case clé cette
case qui est je ne sais pas comment dire
mais en gros si vous l pions h
ces deux colonnes à côté jusqu'à la
promotion sert jusqu'à la vie qu'à
manger s'il arrive sur cette case là il
va propres profiter des deux stratagème
soit x mais sur les castes de promotion
et c'est nul on ne peut pas l'en déloger
soit ils veulent enfermer votre propre
droit dans la boîte
dès 15h c'est th8 les casses de
promotion et là c'est nul également donc
votre seule solution pour gagner c'est
de mettre le roi angers7
et ensuite de préparer l'avant c'est du
pur h voilà je pense qu'on a fait à peu
près le tour de la question le tour des
finales euro action contre contre roy
tout simplement donc à peu près 50% de
chances de gain ça dépend de la position
et je vous invite donc à revoir tout ça
pour être bien sûr et savoir jouer ces
finales mathématiquement est
parfaitement sans réfléchir puisque
c'est des finales quand même élémentaire
aux échecs
voilà je vous donne rendez vous à